investor e example now what I'm going to
do is walk you through a question which
maybe it seems quite similar to the ones
you've um you've done already I'm going
to walk you through it without using
inverse tree okay I grab a sheet when we
looked at that previous example the
plane flying overhead and the radar that
was tracking it if you remember that I
think we looked at it and we decided
inverse trig was not a good way to go
because you can solve it quite easily
without a mystery and you have to
differentiate in differentiating mystery
is gross so I'm going to solve this
question for you in a second without it
because I think that's still the best
way however I'm then going to show you
how you would solve a with an investor
eat for two reasons number one because
you can number two because you guys know
sometimes exams have this pesky habit of
prescribing a particular method that you
have to use for a question right so even
though you could solve it another way
perfectly fine and you know induction
the classic example a lot of the results
that they ask you to prove like say the
calculus one's way easier to prove with
that induction but they want to see if
you know what you're talking about and
you can actually use that skill in a
place you might not usually ok so that's
all going to show you how the question
works not that much worse but I still
don't prefer it ok so I'm going to take
a question straight out the program I'll
read it for you first just the whole
thing so you can get an idea in your
head and then I read it again slower so
you can sort of get the key details and
maybe draw yourself a rough diagram we
can start solving it ok so here we go um
a rope from the bow of a dinghy is
attached to a winder like winding 12 a
winder on the wharf the wharf is 3
meters above the bow level of the dinghy
if the ropes being wound in at a rate of
two meters per second at what rate is
the angle between the rug and the wharf
decreasing when the DS four meters from
the wharf
catch all that lets traffic in slower
you've got a wolf and you've got their
dinghy okay i am a now that I've start
reading the question i'm just going to
call it a boot because i don't know why
it's such a weed work anyway so you've
got a wharf okay and it's above the
water ok there's my woof and it's got a
arm a wider here so like some Joe it's
got like a handle on it which is
attached to a rope which is attached to
the boat so here's my knees my boat okay
and this thing is really in the boat
from from explorer there's the bar on
the end okay the wolf is three meters so
the wharf is three meters above the bowl
level of the do so we're calling this
three meters okay if the ruse being
round in at a rate of two meters of
second so they're turning this thing
right and this guy is getting shorter
and shorter and shorter and I guess
because you know it's not lifting it off
because of gravity this thing Zack
you're moving in but this day is getting
sooo m/s I guess short up so towards
that direction at what rate is the angle
between the rope and the wharf the right
of the war now what raised the angle are
decreasing when the D is four meters
from the wharf so that's this distance
here
all right do you need me to repeat any
part of that again or that sort of
enough what's addy all right now um
let's have a look at this by the way
just as a minor detail you can see I put
this in as 3 meters and I put this isn't
as 4 meters with sort of dotted lines
can anyone suggest why I might do that
why make women you do that good so this
3 meters is always 3 meters whatever
situation the question is dealing with
but this 4 meters it's for me this at a
particular time that's the time i will
be interested in later ok so at one
instant it's 4 meters and then it'll be
shorter sometimes along with other times
so I've just put that in dotted so that
I can distinguish between us alright so
um where do we start well usually I say
okay what's what's given to us apart
from all of these measurements okay well
there was a rate given to us and I need
to be able to describe it in some terms
right so this life here which is
changing the rope what do you think we
should call it L I suppose you could oh
I called it our for rope is that too
that's a different ah yes for Apple okay
you can call if you want like as it
doesn't matter Chris um therefore I've
got that distance the length of the Rope
changing so what's given to me is dr on
dt what is the r dt minus 2 it's getting
sure that yeah okay so just another
reason why you're gonna be careful when
you say this watch out fer on your
diagram when you put an arrow or
something like that you've got to make
sure you know what directions okay
that's given what i want to find is what
i would find d whatever this angle is
whatever you called it I've caught a
fear so defeat up on duty how it's
changing over time so you know enough by
this point what do you put off the here
where do I go next
chain rule yeah so I'm going to have
defeated on now this one you can
probably say what's the what's the
variable I'm going to be great yeah dr
the only other woman got right and i'm
going to multiply that by the rate that
I know you are indeed okay alright so
now what what do I do I'm gonna have to
bring some tricky in right cuz this the
owner duty quantity I know it's just
that constant but in order to get this
one I need some relationship it's going
feet up and are between an angle and a
side in this right angled triangle that
looks like a side doesn't it in writing
your triangle so what's my relationship
hmm which one should I choose do you
think I've got fear I've got to relate
it to this side which is the hypotenuse
of this triangle and then I get to
choose right so which side should I
related to this is one of the reasons
why i put this in as dotted right you
can't really usable you can use this
except it's not really for right
actually as a variable because this does
this changes as well as well as this
what would it be equal to it would be on
well by Pythagoras if your square root
of a squared minus 9 wouldn't it so
right yeah so I could use that but why
would I use that when I have something
perfectly simple to choose from which is
a much better option okay so James it's
cosine thank you adjacent and hypotenuse
we've got their rental it so I'm going
to good idea cos theta is equal to
adjacent on hypo news okay now i said to
you first we'll change this so that we
avoided industry okay we'll deal with
mystery in a second so if i'm going to
avoiding this tree what am I going to do
here what do i what do I make this
object I want R to be the subject right
then I can work out drm d theta and then
take the reciprocal
ok so if as the subject here I'm just
swapping them really ok so there's our
now when i take the derivative that's um
that's sec beat up then I'll know the
result sect an the sector hmm sector I
think it is sick time is it yeah I think
we're going the other way should we just
do it from scratch ok let's just do it
I'm going to treat this as cos theta to
the power minus one ok so when i
differentiate this chain rule yeah I
prefer chain rule to question rule
because I don't like the question rule
so dr i'm here is equal to what's my
first step I'll just wrap the three down
yeah is that okay now what power down so
minus out the front I've got cos theta
to the power of reduce it by one now
what
30 to be the inside bike chain rule yeah
so I've got latest side here at the
front so minus 30 I know why so am i
stepping it up that's a plus and there's
our cross square theta okay now that is
that is sector now why didn't I go
toward sec 10 because I actually don't
want DRD theta do I I actually want to
defeat Iran dr so i'm going to take the
reciprocal of this and then i'm going to
work with that ok so that's on the theta
i wanna come out to here and i
substitute it in just remember to take
the reciprocal so that's going to be
closed squared data on 3 sine theta x
minus 2 so I'm just going to slap the
minus 2 at the front he happy with that
okay so there's our derivative now I
wanted this is the rate that theater is
changing for the time I wanted it at a
particular point what particular point
don't want which point was i after my
trust any point yeah good when this was
for hence my dotted line right so the
problem with that though is that it has
nothing to do with theta or not directly
anyway okay so if I know that this is
for I want to know what cos theta and
sine theta rar right so i would say when
I don't give them a distance but I can
say that's 3 this is 4 what's r equal to
5 so when r z 25 i can say cos theta is
equal to wells just three or five right
and sine theta is equal to opposite by
hypotenuse four in five ok so now these
values i can take in so when r is equal
to 5 is minus two x all over
okay alright so let's simplify out a
little bit this is going to be 9 i'm 25
so I've got minus 18 1 25 on top this is
12 15 yeah this 5 will make this a 5 I
can go by six so this will be covered
too this will become a three so I'm
getting minus three over tape hey check
out no silly of me yes no I'm not there
yet it's ok for a right how long is now
why you have a tent that was that was a
question now by the way what are the
units radians per second ok now by the
way last time when we were thinking
about the plane right I post you the
question why radians and doc degrees did
anyone think about any further I would
too busy catering for dodgeball that's
ok let me explain I won't give you the
full expression but it's actually a lot
simpler than you think the reason why
this is going to be in radians is
because we're dealing with calculus and
when you're dealing with calculus you
have to be in reddit why well I want you
to see how far you can remember back
when we were doing this when we were
proving this result this is kind of your
introductory calculus trig result right
um how do we prove it there were two
ways we went about it firstly we looked
at the graph and we said well they kinda
when you describe its gradient its
greeting he is like one and its gradient
he's like zero we sort of mapped it out
and you're like oh that looks like cars
so we knew it was sort of in that
general direction right but that was not
really a very ouch it's not a very
vigorous proof so if you remember we did
a vigorous proof it had to do with this
limit um remember it sine X X next you
remember that at all vaguely ring your
bell and so we got we established this
limit as X approaches zero sine X on X
was equal to one ok now we needed that
when we were doing first principles for
this ok but here's the kicker where did
these results come
from do you remember they came from
Radian measure they came from the size
of an angle you had this circle and
there was a there was a sector here and
it was getting smaller than the sorry
but triangles getting taller than sector
bottom are you can look back in your
notes if you want but the key is that
these results which look like they're
graphing thing really sign and then X
and then tan they really come from
looking at the area of a circle in
different parts of it okay so seeing as
all of these results only work in
radians all of these results only work
in radians so all of these results only
work in radians so this only works in
radians doesn't make sense if it's on
degrees okay you have to multiply
everything by y nadie on pie okay which
I suppose you can do but all of your
numbers would be disgusting okay all
right now there's a solution is y over
10 how do we do it with inverse Street
which crucial step is different can you
tell me yeah good at this point actually
maybe even one before that when I'm
going for my derivative instead of
working out DRD theta taking the
reciprocal using inverse tree allows me
to work out the theater on dr directly
okay so let me show you how it works
I've